PROFESSOR: We've been spending
quite a few lectures so
far discussing Szemeredi's
regularity lemma,
it's applications in variants
of the regularity Lemma.
So I want to spend one more
lecture, before moving on
to a different
topic, to tell you
about other extensions
and other perspectives
on Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
So hopefully, you
all will become
experts of the regularity
lemma, especially
the next homework
problem set where
there will be plenty of
problems for you to practice
using the regularity lemma.
So one of the things that I
would like to discuss today
is a hypergraph extension of
the triangle removal lemma.
So as we saw, the
triangle removal lemma
was one of the important
application of Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma.
OK.
So that works inside graphs,
but now let's go to hypergraphs.
In particular, even in
the case of three uniform
hypergraphs where--
so let's set some terminology.
So when r uniform hypergraph, or
simply abbreviated as r graph,
consists of a vertex
set and an edge
set where the edge set
consists of r couples.
So the edges are r element
subsets of the vertex set.
So r equals the 2 corresponds
to the graph case.
And you can talk about
sub-graphs or density,
various counts all analogously
to how we did it for graphs.
And you can imagine what
the hypergraph removal
lemma might look like.
So let me write
down a statement.
That for all r graph h and
epsilon bigger than zero,
there exists a delta such that--
so the last time, there was
some complaints about sentences
going on too long, so let
me try to cut sentences
into smaller parts.
So if g is an end vertex r graph
with small number of copies
of each, so h is sub-graphs,
then g can be made h free.
So far, everything's still
the same as in the graph case,
but now in the graph
case, the number of edges
is quadratic, most quadratic.
Here, it's a most
n to the r, so I
want to make this
graph, this r graph,
h free by removing
less than epsilon
n to the r edges from g.
So that's the statement of
the hypergraph removal lemma.
So it's an extension of
the graph removal lemma.
Any questions about
the statement?
So before discussing
the proof, let
me show you why you might
care about this statement.
And we used the triangle removal
lemma to deduce Roth's theorem.
Remember, there was a graph
theoretic set up where
start with a 3-AP-free subset.
We set up a graph,
and then that graph
has some nice
properties that allows
us to use a corollary of
the triangle removal lemma,
namely the corollary that says
that if you have a graph, where
every edge sits on
exactly one triangle,
then it has a sub
quadratic number of edges.
So we can do a similar
type of deduction
showing that the hypergraph
removal lemma implies
Szemeredi's theorem.
So that's what we'll do.
So let's deduce
Szemeredi's theorem
from the hypergraph
removal lemma.
So recall Szemeredi's
theorem says
that for every fixed
positive integer k,
if a is a subset of 1
through n, that is kp free,
has no k term
arithmetic progressions,
then the size of
a is sub-lineal.
Instead of illustrating how to
do this proof for general k,
I'm just going to do it for
the case of k close to 4.
And you can look at the
proof and it will be clear
how to generalize.
So we'll just illustrate
the proof for 4-APs.
Now, before even showing
you what this proof looks
like, you might wonder,
do we really need
the hypergraph removal lemma?
Could it be that with
the graph removal
lemma and a more clever
choice of a graph,
you could prove Szemeredi's
theorem using just that.
So we set up some
graph previously
where triangles
correspond to 3-APs.
Maybe you can set
up some other graph
where some other kinds of
structure correspond to 4-APs.
And it turns out the
answer is emphatically no.
So there's a very good
reason for this that for--
these are things which we might
go into more when we discuss
additive combinatorics,
but 4-APs
is a pattern that's sometimes
called complexity two.
Where as 3-APs is a pattern
which is called complexity one.
I won't go into the precise
definitions of what this means,
but the message is that you
cannot prove the 4-AP theorem
with just graph machinery.
You really have to use
something stronger.
That there is a very real sense
in which just a graph removal
lemma is at least-- or
Szemeredi's theorem,
Szemeredi's regularity
lemma is not enough.
And so we really do have
to go to hypergraph.
And this extra
layer of complexity,
like in this word sense
of the complexity,
introduces also additional
difficulties in there.
So that there makes
significantly harder
than graph removal lemma.
So I won't even
show you anything
that's close to
a complete proof,
but I will illustrate
some of the ideas
and highlight some of
the difficulties today.
But deducing Szemeredi's theorem
from the hypergraph removal
lemma is actually not so bad.
So I will show you how
to do that right now.
So from the hypergraph
removal lemma,
even just for three
uniform hypergraph, even
for tetrahedra-- so into the
triangles graph, tetrahedron,
we can have the following
corollary analogous to all
we have for triangles.
So if g is a three graph such
that every edge is contained
in a unique tetrahedron, then g
has sub-cubic number of edges.
So completely
analogous to the one
we have for triangles and
the proof is identical.
You read the proof
and everything
works exactly the same way,
once you have the removal lemma.
By tetrahedron, I mean
the complete graph
on four vertices.
Complete three graph
of four vertices.
OK?
So you four vertices and you
look at all possible triples
of vertices.
All right.
So now let's prove
Szemeredi's theorem, at least
the 4-AP case.
The general case is
completely analogous.
Of course, you have
to go to higher order.
Instead of three graphs, you
have to look at r graphs.
So just as in the proof
of Roth's theorem,
we're going to set up
some particular three
graph where let's look
at a certain modulus
m being 6n plus 1.
The exact number is
not so important here.
I really just wanted
this number is bigger
than 3n and it's co-prime to 6,
as well as t sum divisibility's
by 2 and 3, that will be useful.
So let's build a
4-partite three graph
g where the four vertex
parts x, y, z, w, they all
have m vertices each.
And I'll show you
what the edges are.
So four vertices, little
x and big X and so on.
So here are the rules
for putting the edges.
I'll just tell you
exactly what they are.
So I put in an edge
xyz if and only
if the following expression
3x plus 2y plus z lies in a.
I put in the edge xyw if and
only if 2x plus y minus w
lies in a.
OK?
So xzw if and only if x
minus the minus 2w lies in a.
And finally, yzw if and only
if minus y minus 2z minus 3w
lies in a.
So these are the
rules for putting
in edges of this hypergraph.
Of course, you have
this hypergraph.
And you might be wondering, why
did I choose these expressions?
So if it's not clear
yet, it will soon
be very clear why we do this.
Just as in the proof
of Roth's theorem
using triangle removal lemma,
let's examine the tetrahedra
in this three graph.
So what are the tetrahedra?
Notice that xyzw
is a tetrahedron.
So if all three
triples are present, if
and only if all four of
these expressions lie in a.
Well, just like in a
proof of Roth's theorem,
these four expressions
form a 4-AP.
And the common
difference is minus
x minus y minus z minus w.
OK?
So they were chosen to
satisfy this property.
But furthermore, notice
that I can't just
put any expressions in.
I put these expressions in
with the very nice property
that the i-th linear form does
not use the i-th variable.
So each expression
really corresponds
to an edge in this three graph.
All right.
But we started with a
set a that is 4-AP free.
It follows that you don't have
this kind of configurations
unless the common
difference is zero.
So the only
tetrahedra correspond
to these trivial 4-APs.
And just as in the
proof of Roth's theorem
that we saw from
triangle removal lemma,
the conclusion is
that every edge lies
in exactly one tetrahedron.
And therefore, by the
corollary, the number of edges
is equal to little o of m cubed.
But on the other hand,
how many edges are there?
So for each of the
four conditions here,
so for each of these four
parts, the number of edges is,
well, you get to choose x
and y whatever you want.
And the last variable
has a choices.
So this implies that the
size of a is little o of m,
and m is on the same order as
n, and that proves the theorem.
OK.
Any questions so far?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where do we use
the m is co-prime to 6?
PROFESSOR: Great.
Question's where do
we use the condition
that m is co-prime to 6?
Anyone know the answer?
AUDIENCE: To solve for that
last variable, divide by 2 or 3.
PROFESSOR: Great.
So to solve for
the last variable,
we ought to maybe
divide by 2 or 3.
And to do that, you need to
have co-primality with 6.
Yeah, so I'm hiding a
bit of details here.
OK?
But it's a great question.
So if you work out the details
of this statement here,
every edge slicing exactly
one tetra tetrahedron
and also counting
the number of edges,
but more especially,
the first sentence.
You need to actually do
just a tiny bit of work.
Any more questions?
So this deduction is the
same deduction as the one
that we did four
triangles, but you
have to come up with a slightly
different set of linear forms.
And usually, if you're
given a specific pattern,
you know you can play by
hand and try to come up
with a set of linear forms.
You can think about, also,
how to do this generally.
And more generally, this
hypergraph removal lemma
using this type of
ideas, it allows
you to deduce multi-dimensional
Szemeredi theorem.
So if you give me
some pattern, then
a subset of the integer
lattice in the fixed dimension
avoiding that pattern must
have density going to zero.
So we stated this in
the very first lecture.
And I won't spell
all the details,
but you can follow
this kind of framework
and gave you that theorem.
And I will post
the problem where
you asked to do this
for a specific pattern,
namely that of a geometric
square, axis-aligned square.
So if you have
that pattern in z2,
so it's worth thinking about
how would you run this argument
for that pattern in z2.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How close
can the small o m be?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question's how
close can the--
so you're asking what is the
rate, this little o m gives?
Let me address-- OK, so
hold onto this question.
I will address it once
I discuss what is known
about hypergraph removal lemma.
And that's a great
question and there's
a lot of mystery surrounding
what happens there.
OK.
Questions?
Any others?
Great.
So let's discuss this
hypergraph removal lemma.
And as I had warned you already
at the beginning of lecture,
this one is very difficult. So
I mentioned in the very first
lecture that the development
of Szemeredi's regularity lemma
was a stroke of ingenuity.
But this one here--
but we saw that the
proof and we did
the proof of Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma
in one lecture.
And once you understand
it, it's not so bad.
You do the energy increment,
conceptually it's not so bad.
But that when there is
actually incredibly difficult.
It's incredibly difficult both
conceptually and technically.
But I want to at least
illustrate some of the ideas
and give you some sense
of the difficulty,
like why is this difficult.
So as we imagine,
we have graph regularity.
And to prove
hypergraph removal, one
would develop some kind of a
hypergraph regularity method.
And the basic idea in hypergraph
regularity or just regularity,
in general, is that I give
you some arbitrary graph
or hypergraph, and you want to
find some kind of partitioning,
some kind of regularization into
some bounded number of pieces,
some bound amount of
data so that that's
a good approximation
for the actual graph.
Just like in the
graph regularity case.
So let's try to do this.
So what does this
partition even look like?
So here's an attempt.
And of course, I
call it an attempt
because eventually,
it will not work.
But it's a very natural
first thing to try.
And maybe, I shouldn't call
it naive because it's actually
not a bad idea to begin with.
OK, so let's see.
So suppose you were
given a three graph g.
I'm going to just to
help you remember what's
the uniformity of each graph.
I will denote in parentheses,
in the superscript,
so just help you remember
that this is the three graph.
So in geometry, they also
do this with manifolds.
So if you put an n on
top, it's an n manifold.
But this 3 is for three graph.
Suppose we partition the
vertex set of this three graph
similar to proof of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
Think about how the proof of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
goes.
So you have this partition,
but in the proof,
there is this
iterative refinement.
And each step you say, well, I
have this notion of regularity.
If it doesn't
satisfy regularity,
I can keep cutting
things up further.
So what's the
notion of regularity
that might get you some
kind of vertex partition?
Can anyone think of a
notion of a regularity
for three uniform hypergraphs?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So the same
sort of thing, [INAUDIBLE]
variations like [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So let me try to
rephrase what you're saying.
So if we have a
notion of regularity,
let's say I have three
vertex sets, V1, V2, V3.
And I want that the density
between these three,
they do not differ from--
if I restrict these
vertex sets to subsets
that are not too small.
Does this make sense?
So here, this d is the
fraction of triples that
are edges of the hypergraph.
So this is the
natural extension,
natural generalization of
the notion of regularity
that we saw earlier for graphs.
And indeed, it's a
very natural notion.
it is a nice notion.
And actually, if
you use this notion,
if you use more or less
precisely what I've written,
you can run through the entire
proof of Szemeredi's graph
regularity lemma and produce
a regularity theorem that
tells you given an arbitrary
three uniform hypergraph,
you can decompose the
vertex set in such a way
that most triples of vertex
sets have this property.
So the same proof as Szemeredi's
regularity lemma implies--
so I won't write down
the entire statement,
but you get the idea.
So for every
epsilon, there exists
m such that we can partition
into the vertex set
into at most m parts, even
equitable, if you like,
so that at most an epsilon
fraction of triples or parts
are not epsilon regular in
the sense that I just said.
So it's literally
is the same proof.
So you really look at the
proof and then you get that.
OK?
So far everything seems
pretty good, pretty easy.
OK.
So why did I say,
initially, that actually,
hypergraph regularity
is incredibly difficult?
So what not good about this one?
Also remember, in
our application
of the regularity method,
there were three steps.
What are they?
Partition, clean, and count.
OK.
So partition, OK,
you do partition.
Clean, well, you do
some kind of cleaning.
But counting,
that's a big thing.
And that's something
that wasn't so hard.
We had to do a little bit of
work, but it wasn't so hard.
And you can ask, is there
a counting lemma associated
to this regularity lemma?
And the answer is
emphatically no.
And I want to convince you that
for this notion of regularity,
there's no counting lemma.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this
version true, though?
PROFESSOR: It is true.
So you ask, is
this version true?
So this statement is true
with this definition.
And you can prove
it by literally
rerunning the entire proof of
Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma.
So the regularity statement
I've written down is true,
but it is not useful.
For example, it cannot be
used to prove the tetrahedron
removal lemma because if you
try to run the same regularity
proof of the removal lemma, you
run to the issue that you do
not have a counting lemma.
OK.
So why is it that you do
not have a counting lemma?
So let me show you an example.
And keep in mind that the
notions of regularity,
they are supposed to model
the idea of pseudo randomness,
which is the topic we'll
explore in further length
in the next chapter.
But the idea of
pseudo randomness
is that I want some graph
which is not random,
but in some aspects look random.
So this is an important concept
in mathematics and computer
science, and it's a
very important idea.
But of course, you can
generate a pseudo random object
by just taking a random
object, and it should hopefully
satisfy some properties
of pseudo randomness.
So let's see what this
notion of regularity,
how it works even for
random hypergraph.
What's a random hypergraph?
So there are different ways to
generate a random hypergraph.
One way is to have
a bunch of triples
all appearing
uniformly at random,
independently at random.
So I have a bunch
of possible triples
that I can make as edges,
each one I flip a coin.
But there's a
different way, and let
me show you a different way to
generate a random three graph.
Let me give you two
parameters, p and q.
They are constants
between 0 and 1.
So let's build first a
graph, so a random two graph
which I'll call g2.
So this is just the
Erdos-Renyi random graph, gnp.
The usual one where you
flip a coin for each edge
so that each edge appears with
probability p independently.
And now, I make the actual
three graph that want, g3,
by including every triple,
so every triangle of g
has an edge.
So here, an edge
means a triple--
edge is three vertices
in the hypergraph--
with probability q.
So it's a two-step process.
I first generate a
random graph, and then I
look at the triangles
on top of that graph.
And each triangle I include as
a triple with a probability q.
If you like, q be even one.
So I do a random graph
and my hypergraph
is a set of triangles.
And let's compare
this construction
to the more naive version
of a random hypergraph where
we look at this
hypergraph of graph
where I put in each triple
appearing independently
with probability p cubed q.
So these are two
different constructions
of random hypergraph.
And you can check that they
have basically the same edge
density.
So how many edges
appear in the first one?
While the density of
triangles in g2 is p cubed,
and each of those triangles
appears an edge further
with probability q.
So they have similar
edge densities.
And furthermore, you can
check that this condition here
is true for both graphs.
So both graphs satisfy this
notion of epsilon regularity
as justifying with
high probability.
OK.
Great.
So if you have the counting
lemma, it should give you
some prediction as to
the number of tetrahedra
that come directly from the
densities, in particular,
they should be the same for
these two constructions.
But are they the same?
So the density of tetrahedra
in the first case,
actually, let's do
the second case first.
In b, so what's the
density of tetrahedra?
So if I have four vertices,
so each of those three edges
appear uniformly at
random, independently,
so the density of tetrahedra
is just the edge density
raised to the power of 4.
What about the first one?
AUDIENCE: 6.
PROFESSOR: So in the first
one, to get a tetrahedra,
the underlying graph
needs to have a k4.
So p raised to 6, and then
on top of that, I want 4q's.
So p raised to 6, q raise to 4.
And when p is different,
these numbers are different.
So this is an
example showing why
there is no counting
lemma because you
have two different
graphs that have
the same type of
regularity and densities,
but have vastly different
densities of tetrahedra.
Any questions
about this example?
It shows you, at least, why
this naive attempt does not
work, at least if you follow
our regularity recipe.
But in any case, it's
good for something.
So you do not have a counting
lemma for tetrahedra,
but you can still
salvage something.
So it turns out
there is a counting
lemma if your graph h--
if this r graph h is linear.
So linear means every pair of
edges intersecting at most one
vertex.
So for example, if you look at--
so hypergraph or each line
is an edge of triples.
So that's a linear hypergraph
because each pair intersecting
at most one vertex.
Tetrahedron is not linear.
Two faces of a tetrahedron
can intersect in two vertices.
OK.
So we can try to prove
that this is true.
And actually, the proof
is basically the same
as the counting lemma
that we saw for graphs.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How many edges
can a linear graph have?
PROFESSOR: The
question, how many edges
can a linear hypergraph have?
You mean, given the
bounded number of vertices.
OK.
I'll leave you to
think about it.
Any more questions?
But for the graph that
we really care about,
namely tetrahedra which
relates to Szemeredi's theorem,
this method does not work.
So what should we do instead?
Let's come up with a different
notion of regularity.
And that's somewhat
inspired by that example
up there where we need to look
at not just triple densities
between three vertex
sets, but also
what happens to triples
that sit on top of a graph.
So we should come up with
some notion of an edge density
on top of two graphs.
So given a, b, and c being
edge sets of a complete graphs,
so these are graphs
a, b, and c--
you should think
of them as graphs--
and a three graph g, we can
define this quantity b of abc--
so there's always a hidden
g which I'll usually omit--
to be the fraction
of triples xyz
where xyz are such that
they sit on top of abc.
So yz lie in a.
xz lie in b.
xy lie in c.
So diffraction off such triples
that are actually triples of g.
In the case when
abc are the same,
it's asking what fraction
of triangles are edges of g.
But you are allowed to
use three different sets.
So think of abc as red,
green, blue masking
for fractions of red,
green, blue triangles
that are actually triples
of the hypergraph.
All right.
So now, we can try to come up
with some notion of regularity.
And as you might
expect, at this point,
it's not sufficient to
partition the vertex set.
Instead, we'll go further.
We'll partition the edge
set of the complete graph.
So we'll partition the
set of pairs of vertices.
Let's partition each set
of the complete graph
as a union of
graphs such that we
would like a similar type
of regularity condition
but for those
types of densities.
Such that for most ijk such
that we have lots of triangles
on top of these three
graphs in the partition.
So for most ijk, such that this
is the case, this partition,
so this triple is regular in
the sense that for all subgroups
with not too few copies,
so not too few triangles,
on top of these a's.
One has that the density,
the triple density,
among the g's is similar to
the triple density on top
of the a's.
So I'm doing some
kind of partition
where g1 is like that.
g2 like that, and g3 that.
And what I'm saying is that if
you take subset of g1, g2, g3
so that there are still
lots of triangles,
and that's analogous to
this condition of a i's
now being too small, then
counting the number of triples
to the fraction of those
triangles that are edges of g.
That fraction is
roughly the same when
you pass down to sub-graphs.
Don't worry about
the specific details,
and I'm not going to try to
give you the specific details.
But think about the analogy
to instead of partitioning
the vertex set, we are
partitioning the edge
set of a complete graph.
But actually,
hypergraph regularity
involves one more
step, namely that we
need to further regularize these
g's via partitioning the vertex
set.
Similar to what happens in
Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma, but actually more similar
to the strong regularity lemma
that we discussed last time.
So the data of
hypergraph regularity
is not simply a partition of the
vertex set, but it's twofold.
One is a partition of the edge
set of the complete graph,
so partition of
the vertex pairs,
into pseudo random
graphs, so in into graphs,
so that the hypergraph g
sits pseudo randomly on top.
And furthermore,
there's also a partition
of the vertex set of g so
that the graphs in part one
are extremely pseudo random
with respect to this partition.
And this idea of
extremely random
we saw in the last lecture,
you have some the sequence
of epsilons that depend
on how many parts
you have in the first
step of the regularity.
OK.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What happens
with triples g's that don't
have a lot of triangles?
PROFESSOR: The question is, what
happens to triples of g's that
do not have lots of triangles?
So they are similar
to in graphs,
you have these small
sets of vertices.
So you have to deal
with them somehow,
but I'm, again, leaving out
all these technical details.
And in fact, I am writing
down a very sketchy version
of hypergraph regularity.
You could write down a
more precise version.
You can find it in literature.
In fact, you can find
more than one version
of the statement of hypergraph
regularity in literature.
And they're not all
obviously equivalent.
It actually takes
a lot of work even
to show that different
versions of the statement
are equivalent to each other.
And it's still somewhat
mysterious as to what
is the right, the most
natural formulation
of hypergraph regularity.
That's something that I
think we still do not yet
have a satisfactory answer.
There was a question
earlier about bounds.
OK.
So what kind of bounds do you
get for hypergraph regularity?
So let me address
that issue now.
So what kind of
bounds do you get?
Well for Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma,
the bound is a power
function because we
have to iterate the
exponential which
comes out of the partitioning.
And in hypergraph regularity,
because of this extremely
pseudo random--
so you are doing some kind of
partitioning the first stage,
and then you are iterating that
on top for the second stage.
Similar to how we did strong
regularity in the last lecture.
So the bounds for
hypergraph regularity
is also iterated power
which we saw last time,
and this is known as a Wowzer.
So it's even worse
than graph regularity.
And just like in the
case of graph regularity,
this was Wowzer type
bound is necessary,
at least for most statements,
any of these useful statements
of hypergraph regularity.
What about the applications?
So applications to
multi-dimensional
Szemeredi's theorem--
OK, so first of all to
Szemeredi theorem, well,
you can prove Szemeredi
theorem this way
and you would get inverse
Wowzer type bounds,
which is it's not so great.
But there are better proofs.
So there are more efficient
proofs quantitatively.
So for Szemeredi's theorem,
the best result for general k
is due to Gowers' which tells
you that a must be, at most,
n over something that's
log log n raised to power
some constant c depending on k.
That's for k equals 3 and 4,
you can do somewhat better
before general k.
This is the best bounds so far.
But for multi-dimensions, for
multi-dimensional patterns,
it turns out that--
well, historically,
the first proof
of the multi-dimensional
Szemeredi's theorem
was done using
Ergodic theory which
has even worse bounds compared
to this approach in that
the Ergodic theoretic proof
gives no bounds because it has
to use compactness
arguments, so they actually
give no quantitative bounds.
And one of the motivations
for this hypergraph regularity
method, the removal
lemma, is to produce
quantitative proof of
multi-dimensional Szemeredi's
theorem.
So in general, still
the best bounds
come from this removal lemma,
so hypergraph removal lemma.
Although in special
cases, and really,
not that many special
cases, but really just
the case of a corner
as we saw earlier
you have somewhat better bounds.
So for corner, you
have bounce, which
have density like polylog log.
But even for a
geometric square, we
do not know any Fourier
analytic methods,
we do not know other methods.
And this is basically
the best bound coming out
of hypergraph regularity.
And there are
serious obstructions
for trying to use Fourier
methods to do other patterns
such as geometric square.
OK?
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what do the bounds
look like for higher degree
uniformity.
Are they still just Wowzers?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what are the bounds like
for higher degree uniformity?
So this is Wowzers for free
uniform, and for full uniform,
you iterate Wowzer.
So you go up in
Ackermann hierarchy.
You iterate Wowzer,
you get a four uniform
hypergraph regularity
lemma as so.
Let's take a short break.
So the second topic I
want to discuss today
is a different approach to
proving Szemeredi's graph
regularity lemma.
And this is a good segue
into our next topic,
the next lecture, which is
about pseudo random graphs,
in particular, the idea of
the spectrum eigenvalues,
in particular, play
a central role.
So I want to consider a
spectral approach giving
an alternative way to prove
the Szemeredi regularity lemma.
And if you're already
sick of the regularity
lemma at this point, this
will be the last topic
on regularity lemma
for now, although it
will come up again
later in this course
when we discuss graph limits.
But for now, this is the
last thing I want to say.
And just like the discussion
about hypergraph regularity,
it will be somewhat sketchy.
So this idea has appeared
in literature in the past,
but it was popularized by
many good things in life
by Terry Tao's blog.
So it's a good place to
look up a discussion of what
I'm about to say.
OK.
So we saw the proof
of regularity lemma
via this iterated
partitioning and keeping
track of our progress
through the use of an energy.
But here's a
different perspective,
namely if we start
with a graph g,
I can look at the
adjacency matrix a sub g.
So this is the n
by n matrix where
n is a number of vertices
whose i j-th is zero
if i is not adjacent to j,
and 1 if i is adjacent to j.
So this is a pretty
standard thing
to look at to associate
a graph to this matrix.
So this graph here would
be like that and so on.
It's a real symmetric matrix
and that's always pretty nice.
Symmetric matrices have
lots of great properties
that will be convenient to use.
In fact, if you're
like myself, if you're
too used to working
with symmetric matrices,
you forget that some
of these properties
actually do not apply in general
to non-symmetric matrices.
But it is symmetric,
so we're happy.
So for symmetric matrices, we
have a set of real eigenvalues.
We have real eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
And for now, let me enumerate
the eigenvalues by lambda 1
through lambda n, so
multiplicity included,
and I sort them according to the
size of their absolute value.
So the spectral theorem
tells us a decomposition.
So here again, we're using
the a as real symmetric.
So it tells us
that this matrix a
can be written as the sum
coming from the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors where the
u i's are the eigenvectors,
but I can choose them so that
they form an orthogonal basis
orthonormal basis, so
they're all unit vectors.
So when I say the spectrum,
I mean this data also,
specifically, this
set of eigenvalues.
All right.
So let's go through some basic
properties of the spectrum.
So first, how big
can the lambdas be?
So I claim that--
so first of all, the sum of the
squares of these lambdas is--
let me not even
call this a lemma,
so it's just an observation.
So the sum of the
squares is this one.
So this is the
trace of a squared,
which is also the sum of
the squares of the entries.
So here, I'm always using
that a is real symmetric--
sum of squares of entries of a.
And the case when you have
a being an adjacency matrix,
this is simply twice the number
of edges, which is at most n
squared.
So that's always a
good thing to remember.
OK?
So as a result, the i-th
eigenvalue cannot be bigger
than what?
So you have i eigenvalues.
So they're sorted
in decreasing order.
So the i-th eigenvalue
cannot be too large,
particular it cannot be
larger than n over root i.
Because otherwise, the sum of
the first i eigenvalue squared
would exceed n squared.
So these things, they do decay.
So second observation
is that if you
have some epsilon and
an arbitrary function,
so this is known as
a growth function.
That's just a name,
don't worry about it.
So which we'll call f.
So its function from
the positive integers,
and for convenience,
I'm going to assume that f
of j is always at least j.
For every j there
exists some c which
depends only on your epsilon
and this growth function.
So this growth function
plays the same role
as the sequence of
decaying epsilons
in these strong
regularity lemma.
So there exists
some constant bound
such that for every graph g
and ag as above, so associated
with the lambdas and u's, there
exists a j less than c such
that if I sum up the
eigenvalues squared
for eigenvalues i index
between j and c of j,
the sum is fairly small.
It's at most epsilon n squared.
I'll let you ponder
that for a second.
So choose your favorite
growth function.
It can be as quickly
growing as you can.
It can be exponential,
power, or whatever.
And it's saying that I can
look up to a bounded point
so that this stretch
of spectrum squared
is, at most, epsilon n squared.
Question.
AUDIENCE: What is c of j?
PROFESSOR: F of j.
Thank you.
Well, the statement
hopefully will become clearer
once I show you the proof.
OK.
So here's how you
would prove it.
So you first let j1
equal to 1, and I
obtained the subsequent
j's by applying f to j.
So I claim that one cannot
have this inequality violated
for too many of these j i's.
So one cannot have the sum
going between jk and jk plus 1
for all k from 1
to 1 over epsilon.
Let's change this to zero.
But you cannot have this because
if you had this then you sum up
all of these inequalities you
would get that the total sum
would exceed and squared, which
would violate the inequality
about sum of the
squares of the spectrum.
And so therefore, so thus
to the claimed inequality,
so this is true
star holds for sum j
equal to ji so jk where k
is less than 1 over epsilon.
And this j, in
particular, is less than--
well, whatever it
is, it's bounded.
So it's less than f
applied to itself at most 1
over epsilon times--
OK.
So this should look
somewhat familiar.
And I'll ask you to
think about, later on,
how this proof of spectral proof
of Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma compare to the
proof that we saw earlier.
And you should see where
the analogous step is here.
This is that density.
This is the energy
increment step.
All right.
OK.
So what's the regularity
decomposition?
So I give you this graph.
I give you this
adjacency matrix.
And I want be able
to find a partition,
but there's a different
way to view a partition.
So this is, I think,
a important idea
which, again, is
popularized by Terry Tao,
that instead of looking
at things as a regularity
partition, we can view
these ideas as regularity
de-compositions.
Namely, pick j as in the lemma
and I now write my adjacency
matrix a sub g as a sum
of three matrices, which
we'll call a structured plus
a small plus a pseudo random.
Where a structured equals to
the sum for basically that sum,
this sum here, so this
spectral de-competition
but only for the first
j minus 1 eigenvalues.
So those of you
coming from or who
have taken classes in
something like Statistics
might recognize this as a
principal component analysis.
So this has many names.
It's a very powerful idea.
You look at the
top spectral data,
and that should describe
you most of the information
that you care about about a
graph or a matrix, in general.
The small piece is the sum
but only for i between j
and f of j.
And the pseudo random piece
is for i at least f of j.
OK.
So we decompose this adjacency
matrix into these three pieces.
And the question now
is, what does this
have to do with Szemeredi's
graph regularity lemma?
So what do the
individual components
correspond to in the version
of the regularity lemma
that you've seen and
are now familiar with?
So here is what's going on.
So I want to show you that
this structured piece roughly
corresponds to the partition.
So this is the
bounded partition.
And the small piece
roughly corresponds
to the small fraction
of irregular pairs.
And the pseudo
random piece roughly
corresponds to the idea
of pseudo randomness
between pairs.
First, to understand what the
spectral data have anything
to do with partitions,
let me remind
you a basic fact about
how the spectrum, how
the eigenvalues of a
real symmetric matrix
relate to other
properties of this matrix.
And namely, this
notion of a spectral
radius or sometimes
called spectral norm.
So far I'm only going to
discuss real symmetric matrices.
So many of the things
I will say are not
true for if you're not
in a real symmetric case.
So the spectral radius
spectral norm of a
is the largest eigenvalue
of a in absolute value.
And this quantity turns out
to be equal to the operator
norm which is the norm of
this a as a linear operator,
namely it is the max
or super, it turns out
to be a max, of av over--
length of av divided
by length of v.
So if you hit it with a unit
vector, how far can you go?
So it's also equal to
this bi-linear form.
If you hit it from left
and right by unit vectors,
how big can you get?
So for real symmetric
matrices, these quantities
are equal to each other.
And that will be
an essential fact
for relating the spectral data
with combinatorial quantities.
All right.
So if you give me
this de-composition,
how can I produce
for you a partition?
Basically, you can
look at a structure
which has its state in
its data a bounded number
of eigenvectors.
And by rounding, we can
basically round these guys so
when you round the
individual values by rounding
the coordinate values--
So let's pretend that they
take only a bounded, let's see,
a small number of values.
So just to simplify
things in your mind,
pretend for a second--
well, of course, this
is far from the truth--
pretend for a second that these
guys are 0 comma 1 valued.
Of course, that's not going
to be the case but 0 comma
1 or plus/minus 1, if you like.
OK.
So this is definitely not true.
But for the purpose
of exposition,
let's pretend this is the case.
And you can more
or less achieve it
by rounding the individual
values to their nearby closest
multiple of something.
Then the level sets of
these top eigenvectors,
they partition the vertex set
into a bounded number of parts.
So if you, for example, in the
simplified version where you're
only have plus minus 1
values for this eigenvectors,
then you have, at
most, 2 to the j parts.
But you may get some more
because some epsilons,
but for the purpose
of illustration,
let's not worry about that.
And this is basically
the regularity partition.
I want to show that this set
here has very nice properties
that they basically behave
like the regularity partition
we've gotten previously.
So what I would like to show
is that the other two parts,
they do not contribute very much
in the sense of our regularity
partition.
So for example, if you look
at the pseudo random piece,
if I hit it left and right with
indicator vectors of vertex
sets, how big can
this number get?
So this number here is, at
most, while the norm of u times
the norm of this
w which is just--
so let me write down--
so the norm of indicator
of u, norm indicator
of w multiplied by
the operator norm
of the pseudo random part of a.
But these two guys here, so
they're, at most, root n each.
So this number
here is, at most, n
but we know from our hypothesis
on the pseudo random part
of a that the spectral
norm is no more
than this quantity over here.
And by choosing f
appropriately large,
I can make sure that this
number is extremely small.
f to be large compared to
the number of parts in b
partition so this
quantity is small.
And this is basically the
notion of epsilon regularity
that you saw in
the usual version
or version of Szemeredi's
regularity lemma
I presented in
the first version,
in the very first lecture
that we discussed regularity.
This quantity here
is something which
measures the difference
between-- so for now,
if for a second ignore
the middle piece.
If you ignore the
small piece, then this
is precisely the difference
between the actual densities
between u and w and
the predicted density
between u and w.
AUDIENCE: Why is there
a square root here?
PROFESSOR: The question is, why
is there a square root here?
There should not be
a square root here.
Good.
It then becomes a
square root of the--
yeah, so there is
no square root,
but the length of this vector
is the square root of the size
of u which is, at most, n.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you say to be
small in general or just small
like you compare
it to f squared?
Because I guess,
isn't it like going
to be this constant function
that you choose before
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Question is do, how small do
we want this f of j to be?
So I want this quantity to
be quite a bit smaller than,
let's say--
so basically, I want it to
be less than f of n squared,
but f of n over the
number of parts square.
Because this quantity is, let's
say, the sizes of each part.
So let me just be not precise
and say much less than.
So this quantity here is
the size of each part.
And I want to think about
the case when u and w
they lie inside each part.
In which case, I
want the difference
to be much less than epsilon
times the size of the part
squared.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] j is
different based on the graph?
PROFESSOR: Question is, is the
j different based on the graph?
Yes.
And that's also the case for
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
In Szemeredi's regularity lemma,
you don't know when you stop.
But you know that you stop
before a certain point.
OK.
And finally, what's happening
with a small part of a.
So in a small, the sum of
the squares of entries--
so this also has
a convenient name.
It's called the
Hilbert-Schmidt norm.
So the sum of the
squares of the entries.
We basically saw this
calculation earlier,
it's the sum of the squares of
the eigenvalues in which case
we've truncated all
the other eigenvalues.
So the only eigenvalues left are
between j and index between j
and f of j.
And we chose j so that
this number is small.
So a small as in
a bunch of noise,
but no adversarial
noise, if you will,
into your graph, but
only a very small amount,
at most, epsilon amount.
So it might destroy the epsilon
regularity for, let's say,
around epsilon
fraction of pairs.
But that's all it could do.
So all but epsilon
fraction of your pairs
will still be epsilon regular.
And that is the consequence of
Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma that we saw earlier.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't large
F have to be special?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So question, does a large
F have to be special?
The F should be chosen--
if you want to achieve
Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma, you should find this F so
that basically this inequality
is true.
So f should be
quite a bit larger
than the number of parts.
But if you choose even
bigger values of f,
you can achieve more regularity.
And this is akin
to what happened
with strong regularity.
So there's this idea if you
iterate one version regularity,
you can get a strong
version of regularity.
And there's some iteration
happening over there.
So if you choose your f to be
a much bigger function of j,
you can achieve a much
stronger notion irregularity
which is similar
and, perhaps, even
equivalent to strong regularity
that we discussed last time.
So you get to choose what
f you want to put in here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
make it equitable?
PROFESSOR: The question is,
how do you make it equitable?
OK.
So let me now discuss that.
So in this case, you can
also do very similar things
to what we've done before,
but to massage the partitions.
It's not entirely clear
from this formulation.
But the message
here is that there's
this equivalence between
operator norm on one hand
and combinatorial discrepancy
on the other hand.
And we'll explore
this notion further
in the next several lectures.